the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones house
of the dragon update video well my
friends we might just have the official
release date for house of the dragon if
any of you go and look up house of the
dragon on imdb's website you will see
that they now have a release date for
the show i will throw that up on my
screen right now
if you look right here at the bottom you
will see a date that says april 3rd
which does fall in line with when a lot
of us already thought house of the
dragon would release
as i've said in many videos before hbo
did release 6 of the 8 seasons of game
of thrones during this month so i always
thought it would make sense if they did
the same thing with house of the dragon
now i will say this date has not been
officially confirmed by hbo i'm not sure
where imdb got this information however
a lot of fans are already saying this
must have leaked from hbo somehow
i honestly don't know if this will be
the date or not but like i said it does
fall in line with what i thought the
date could be
april 3rd also happens to fall on a
sunday the first sunday of that month
actually this also lines up with when
hbo would release new episodes of game
of thrones they would always release
them on a sunday so this would make a
lot of sense now i don't want to go on
and on about this for too long because i
still don't know if it's official or not
but i just wanted to make sure i said
something about this just in case it is
accurate let me know what all of you
think about this do you think it's the
real date anyways for right now i want
to keep this video short and sweet i'm
actually working on some massive videos
right now that i will be releasing very
soon that's sort of why my recent videos
have been so short i think most of you
will like these much bigger videos that
i'm working on right now i'm hoping i
can have the first one released in the
next few days as always make sure you
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
any and all information regarding game
of thrones house of the dragon and a
song of ice and fire i also want to say
thank you for watching the videos i will
see all of you back here for my next one
have a great day everyone i'll see you
soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you